good evening and thanks for joining us
tonight at 11 I'm Sasha Loftis it's been
a busy weekend in Las Vegas right now
the lovers and friends Music Festival is
taking place as you can see here but
that's not all 8 news now reporter
Madison Kimbrough has more near the
festival grounds tonight
yeah there was a lot of traffic to get
here for sure on the 15 freeway
um it took us a while to get here but we
left early Yvonne Miranda visiting from
California for the lovers and friends
Music Festival a millennial's dream
front and center Saturday with all the
hits from the 90s and early 2000s
from Missy Elliott to Mariah Carey Nelly
and even Usher taking a weekend off from
his Vegas residency to show fans a good
time but Lovers and Friends not the only
big event in town
reggae in the desert at the Clark County
government Amphitheater plus the golden
knights playoffs and people also
watching the Kentucky Derby at the
Westgate Superbook I'm a garage sale
driver so I mean I can appreciate the
business of this weekend I've really
enjoyed you know just watching the
Kentucky Derby and it's just always so
much going on this weekend with the uh
with the friends and lovers concert and
everything you know it's really exciting
and from those we spoke to you can't
avoid the traffic delays and lack of
parking but what do you expect when you
have so many events in town at once I've
been to several festivals it's just a
part of drawing in a large audience
traffic comes with it so I just planned
around it I looked up what hotels were
close to the venue and what was walkable
it was busy but the parking lot was full
but fortunately I found a parking spot
that wasn't too far away
now this year temperature wise this year
was significantly significantly rather
cooler than last year during this time
those Madison spoke with were pleased
with the amenities offered like adequate
space for people to walk around plenty
of cool water which was lacking at last
year's Festival